talk to me what do you think about your
favorite uh indian prime minister
freezing the bank accounts of anyone
that's involved yeah involved in the
protests
what are your thoughts yeah i got a
problem with this guy yo talk to me
about it
yo that's yo this is it's getting
tyrannical it's a little bit it's
borderline tyranny in canada i don't
like this guy trudeau
get out of here brown face
get out of here
dude oh you're allowed to say that
you're allowed to say it do you think
that he acts this way because fidel
castro came in his mom
and made him
is that a fact well we know that fidel
castro took his mom on a nice little
trip whoa
and so the rolling stones apparently
whoa oh his mom was a joint mama's a
wild girl but
his dad was a wild boy too here's a side
by side what do you think
i think that there are some similarities
yeah that's crazy
i think there's some similarities
that's why he's that that is why he's
acting like this yeah but he don't got
the charm of castro castro had charisma
yeah this guy don't got that yeah i'm
assuming casper had charisma to be
honest but
he must have had chris i was like chloe
right there right yeah 100 you look at
the pick you're like i can see it mark
what do you think we should do about
this
about the trucker's protest no about the
fact that they're uh freezing banking
counts in canada i was looking into
apparently that's not like uncommon like
like they can do that but they're going
crypto and [ __ ] like that like they're
really it's it's everything now right
yeah i think it's just built into the
canadian constitution though like
it's like under the orders that he put
out or something
and
like they're able to use it to like
freeze terrorist funds if something's
deemed terroristic once they deem a
terrorist activity yeah and but that's
where the uh
the miscarriage of justice is happening
mark
yeah
this is not terrorism
we know terrorism
we in the united states of america know
terramin yeah
um
these are freedom fighters yes
these people oh [ __ ] this is fire move
their trucks drove them
to the capital
of canada toronto toronto yeah sure it's
not the capital mark but i mean
it should be yeah but it isn't
it is
ottawa thank god yeah the great city
within ontario which is a province which
we learned recently we learned that
recently they do not have states up
there that's true there are many
provinces
they drove those trucks up there
to fight for freedom for all of us
this is not a movement in canada this is
not a movement in north america this is
a global movement freedom freedom yeah
is what they're fighting for yes freedom
freedom is what they are going to
deliver freedom freedom like 30 seconds
so keep going freedom freedom stress
stretch
i have a dream
you said someone else already did that
white kids okay
and more white kids
and ottawa
will grow up without having to wear
masks
i have a dream this is the modern dream
i have a dream today okay 20 seconds
the white adults
excited about a pond freezing over
will one day yeah be free
to travel across borders whether they're
vaccinated or not
on their trucks yeah free at last
thank god almighty i'll play it back
keep going
we're free at last
[Music]
salute
[Applause]
you